billionaire Twitter CEO Elon Musk
pulling no punches on what he thinks
about the rise in remote workers it's a
productivity issue but it's also a moral
issue
people should get off the ground high
horse with the work from home
um because they're asking everyone else
to not work from home while they do
yeah what do you think of that Jesse did
you know that Elon Musk beeps a lot
it's amazing it sounds like Gutfeld
exclamation I used to be Pro go into the
office and I've changed positions I
think we should tailor it strategically
to the industry and I stand by that
change of opinion yeah it's interesting
but you're in an industry where you I
mean you have to come into work I I mean
I guess you could you could zoom in but
nobody wants to see that you got to be
here only because I'm on a show with
four other people
if I could do seven by myself alone in a
garage or a truck yeah you'd never see
me again well Dana here's the issue he
basically said it's not fair he said
it's a moral issue do you agree with
that I think it's interesting that he
said that and part of it is the
opportunity costs that are missed for
people who are not here right and then
that this is CEOs across the country are
saying this but his specifically saying
that's morally wrong is that you have
people in sort of the management
executive management who are telling
people they have to come back to the
office while they sit in the Hamptons
yes and that's what he's saying is
morally wrong and I would agree with
that there is a new group of the laptop
class right they get to sit on their
laptop all day go to the garage hang out
go to the coffee shop go to the park and
everybody else is schlepping it into the
city back and forth and part of that
means that you have to there could be
things that you do like improving the
infrastructure so that people can get in
and out easier but it's strange once you
let people stay home for a while yeah
and but like this I get wanting to be
there for the kids school play and the
baseball games and everything so there
might be some ways for flexibility but
he's not wrong about the executives
demanding people to be in the office
when they're not and that what is what
was so bad about all the shutdowns
Harold that people got used to it and
now they don't want to come in
right I mean I agree with agree with
Dane I think his point uh the morale the
moral point of this is you have a group
of people who have a skill set and who
have an ability to have a laptop and
more importantly can work from it
um he's pointing out the hypocrisy of it
we've done it on this show the irony of
people who say we should get back to
work and people should wear masks and
all these things yet they want things
delivered to them they want things
catered to them so you know he's a smart
guy as I I've said on many times on this
show that he is this he's our generation
Steve Jobs I'm 53 years old he's a
technologist that in so many ways is
provocative that is smart that is
willing to to challenge the norms and
for that matter even challenges his own
peers in his industry yeah and judge
this is the thing that he's telling
people they got to come into work but is
he going to be able to do it can they
demand people if they need those workers
and they say I'm not coming in you got
to make a choice right well we got all
these new workers coming in right there
coming to work
yeah okay but look the way I feel about
this is when you come to work and you
engage with people in your line of work
you learn more you know you're kind of
more on your game you're a little more
competitive you know I think I think
it's a good thing for for me anyway you
know and uh I think that people who just
want to stay home uh know that they're
distracted by other things and they're
not totally focused on work if you're
focused on work you do your job and then
you go home when you're done hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else